what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and right now Marvel Studios has a lot
on their plate they have some pretty big
decisions that they have to make sooner
rather than later in fact they pretty
much need to decide what they are going
to do with the future of the MCU right
now and here's the kicker the decisions
that they have to make are pretty much
going to decide if they kind of
completely change their plans for the
MCU or stick to the same plans they've
had and unfortunately yes this does come
for a few reasons but one of them is
definitely because of all of the trouble
that Jonathan Majors is in now here on
the channel we try to remain non-biased
and neutral about the situation with
Jonathan Majors until the court actually
makes a ruling on the case however that
still does cause problems for Marvel
Studios whether he is guilty or not but
there is another key factor that will
determine if Marvel Studios is about to
do a complete Game Changer and simply
rearrange Phase 5 and Phase 6 of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and that is
due to the fact that as we've talked
about many times on the channel Marvel
Studios is President Kevin feige and
Disney CEO currently Bob Iger have both
come out and stated they are now going
to be focusing more on quality and less
on quantity and we knew that the current
schedules were going to take a hit most
likely with just delays that we've
already seen so far but now we are at
risk of a complete and total
rearrangement of Phase 5 and phase six
including what we talked about in
yesterday's video the removal or
replacement of King the Conqueror as the
main villain of the MCU and this may
scare a lot of people and it does of
course sound scary however there are
ways that Marvel Studios could get away
with this and there are other villains
that could come in and take the spot of
King the Conqueror and we'll talk about
that in a bit as well but first and
foremost let's talk about Marvel's
timeline essentially Marvel has about a
little less than two months to kind of
get a road map of what they truly want
to do with the MCU moving forward and
this is because San Diego Comic-Con is
right around the corner Hall h where
Marvel Studios always makes their super
huge announcements and from what we've
heard so far Marvel does have some
pretty big and intense announcements
prepared for us or at least they did but
Hall h is the reason that Marvel Studios
has a little less than two months to
make a pretty big decision right now and
like I mentioned the first decision is
to decide on whether or not one they're
going to keep Kang as the main villain
of the MCU and if they decide that then
two they have to decide if they're going
to recast Jonathan Majors or not this is
an extremely huge decision that will
reshape the MCU as we know it as we
learned yesterday the original plan for
Marvel Studios was not to actually have
King the Conqueror be the big bad of the
Multiverse Saga it wasn't until after
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania where
they saw Jonathan Majors act as king and
of course this was after his performance
as he who remains in Loki season one it
wasn't until after they saw him give
though those really great performances
that they decided this is it we're going
to make Kang the main villain however
what this means was they had a different
plan before to go forward in the MCU
with another big bad and yes Kang has
already been hyped up but it's still not
too late to do that with another villain
now I'll just speak candidly I'm not
saying this is what I would prefer to
happen I actually really love the
premise of Kang and a bunch of his
variants not only fighting over the
Multiverse with the Avengers the X-Men
the Fantastic Four and the other Heroes
but fighting against themselves as well
I really like that however if the MCU
did need a savior to come in there are
characters like Doctor Doom they could
pull in it's been reported and rumored
that Mephisto could be coming into the
MCU that's another one it's also been
reported that Ultron could return in
armor Wars and we've already seen in
Marvel's what if what Ultron truly could
be a Ultron who understands essentially
the entire Multiverse and can Multiverse
jump and in the comics Ultron is known
for returning a lot and I think a lot of
fans were really upset that Ultron was
kind of a one and done for Avengers Age
of Ultron so I think a lot of fans would
be really happy to see him return in a
bigger and badder way they could bring
annihilus in and if they wanted to truly
make a change of Phase 5 and phase six
they could bring in the X-Men sooner
rather than later instead of waiting
till phase seven they could bring them
in in Phase 5 or Phase 6 and have an
X-Men villain like annihilus or Magneto
come in I think Doctor Doom is the best
option my only concern about this is Dr
Doom is probably the best Marvel villain
of course that is up to debate and
everybody has their different tastes but
he is definitely one of the best
villains ever I wouldn't want him to
come in just for Secret Wars and be a
one and done thing I want him to stick
around for a pretty long time at least
10 years at least stay around for as
long as the new X-Men and the new
Fantastic Four team are gonna be around
for but the point is as far as replacing
King we do have options options that
actually were work and it's pretty easy
for a variant of Kang to Simply say well
it's actually not my variance you need
to worry about it's this one person that
has figured out our technology who is
slowly killing a ton of variants
throughout the Multiverse that's the
true threat that's not hard to write in
somewhere now if they do go this route
of course they're going to have to
completely change Phase 5 and phase six
and they're going to have to change some
of the writings of some previous films
that they've done as well nothing too
major but like Shang Chi and the legend
of the 10 rings and Kamala Khan with her
bangle obviously their weapons are some
sort of King Tech so they might have to
somewhat rewrite that a little bit but
still nothing too detrimental but
nonetheless it would require some
changes and a phase 5 and phase six will
need some changes as well now Marvel
Studios for phase five well they're
pretty locked in most has already been
filmed or is being filmed currently
however Marvel Studios can go in and do
some rewrites and change some things
about each specific show or movie in
fact we have just heard that Sasha bear
Cohen was on the set of iron heart this
week doing some reshoots we've also
gotten word of some other reshoots
happening for current MCU projects being
filmed and of course this could be the
result of just needing reshoots or this
could be the result of Marvel Studios
kind of changing some things to fit
their new future for the MCU the biggest
change to Phase 5 would probably be the
removal of Blade we know that it's had
its fair share of problems New Riders
new directors the original script being
bad so bad that they had to throw it
away and start from scratch that means
that this has given them some problems
and they'll most likely move it till
after Avengers Secret Wars the movie
probably didn't have much to do with the
Multiverse Saga anyways it most likely
had to do with the supernatural side of
the MCU now Captain America 4 is
shooting right now and the Thunderbolts
isn't far off either Captain America 4
is most likely going to be pretty
essential for the next Avengers film so
I don't think they'll be scrapping that
and depending on what story they have
written for the Thunderbolts they could
either keep them or move them to after
Secret Wars as well they could kind of
be involved with the Multiverse Saga but
again their involvement in the MCU
typically isn't going to be huge
Avengers Level Threats and situations
that they need to deal with or help the
Avengers with but mostly dirty
government work the kind of work that
the government doesn't want the world to
see them do which is why they have the
Thunderbolts so that could either stay
or go I'm gonna say it's gonna go ahead
and stay but phase six is where it's
really gonna start to change for one we
only know four projects in phase six
Deadpool 3 which is definitely going to
stay at the Fantastic Four which is
going to stay and we're going to call
Avengers King Dynasty Avengers 5 now
because this one we are certainly unsure
of at this point in time and then of
course we have Avengers Secret Wars but
since Marvel has not officially
announced any other projects for phase
six this is where they are most likely
going to either add some new projects or
rearrange what they wanted to do now
recently we went over all of the
projects that we know are coming at some
point in time and some of those might
now have to be pushed back till after
Secret Wars because if they're still
going to keep the Multiverse which I'm
sure they are it's the Multiverse Saga
and we're still going to have Secret
Wars then they might have to make other
stories a priority like Wanda's story
giving us a true Scarlet Witch Solo
movie could help the Multiverse Saga
because she clearly wanted to know how
to jump to other multiverses she was
dreamwalking and she stole America
Chavez so that she could use her to
travel the Multiverse but rest assured
she is probably still very interested in
learning how to do that herself and when
things start to happen like incursions
Doctor Strange is going to look to her
to help so we might not have gotten a
Scarlet Witch Solo movie before Secret
Wars prior to all of these incidents but
we might now do to them so there is some
positive that could come out of this
situation but of course they might
actually cut some projects we knew were
going to be coming like black panther 3.
that probably won't involve the
Multiverse too much there's also shows
like the Wonder Man series coming to
Disney plus they might sideline that as
well and if some of the specials that we
heard are coming are true like Nova and
Ghost Rider unfortunately those might
get sidelined as well the reason is of
course like we've been talking about is
to make room for other projects they
could introduce that help make sense of
the new shift in the phase six schedule
of course all of these projects leading
up to Secret Wars it's still all going
to be about incursions and there's going
to be key characters who have to deal
with that like doctor strange and Clea
the Scarlet Witch and most likely the
Fantastic Four maybe Marvel Studios
decides to get the X-Men involved in
phase six rather than wait until after
fingers crossed they do but right now
Marvel Studios has to make a decision on
what they want to do to move forward and
they don't have a lot of time their
decision could simply make everything
stay the same or it could entirely
change the MCU Phase 5 and Phase 6 as we
knew it so now it's the waiting game but
of course if we hear anything we'll be
sure to do an update video so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news don't forget to like the
video and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well we pick a winner at the
end of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item we also are on patreon now
we also do have an official website as
well that we post to daily and we have a
Discord server if you want to join that
we'll link those in the description and
in the pin comment down below you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf
me